all right you're ready to go all right I
will open up the executive session 1692
the chief can read the script right this
time and I read it right last time hey
Jim all right as chair of the House
executive departments and Administration
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of code 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 20 2004 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note that there is no physical location
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that we
are a providing public access to the
meeting by telephone with additional
access possibilities by video or other
electronic means we are utilizing zoom
for the electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by clicking on the following website
address HTTP colon forward slash forward
slash Zoom dot US /j forward slash nine
four eight six four nine four one eight
two five or dial
dialing one of the following phone
numbers
one nine two nine to zero five six zero
nine nine four one three zero one seven
one five eight five nine to be providing
public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice of the public to
the public of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar C
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there is a problem with access
anybody has a problem please call six
zero three two seven one three six zero
zero or email at HC s @ l EG dot state
dot n h dot u s are joining the meeting
if the public is unable to access the
meeting in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us p.m. smiling senior
House committee researcher is the
meeting host additional host committee
services staff providing support our
Brad Greenland Gen 4 and Kristina Dyer
this is an executive session on House
bill 1692 pursuant to house rule 46 F I
have waived the public hearing on this
bill a work session on the bill was held
on may 14th year zoom webinar he copy
the bill in its amendment in an Indian
amendment to it have been posted on the
main page of the general court website
under the heading remote meetings please
note that all votes that are taken there
in this meeting shall be done by roll
call vote let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting which is required under the
right to know lot and represent a
SciTech representative show it or your
take I represent go Leah are you taking
the attendance or am i you are okay
representative
to it I am present and I have a cat
that's very curious about this
representative Joo Dee a representative
Schmidt I am here in my home alone
representative about to be fifty I think
that's me yes I am at my home my husband
Gene Taylor we'll be in and out of the
room
representative front no I am here home
and alone in the room representative
days are done representative fellows
present home alone in the room
representative fox president I am home
with my son
representative grote home hello
representative merchants home and my
wife a be in and out
representative Pimentel I'm here in my
yard and my sister is within the
vicinity but about it
representative Maguire presents home and
Epsom alone represented as the clerk is
present home alone
representative Bowden home alone in the
room representative prove at the same
fire station small ELC alone at this
time
representative Penta City I am home in
Amherst my wife is running around
somewhere and there's a contractor here
but I'm in a separate room
representative Pearson
representative Kyrsten going once not
did I hear anything no he's not ready
not here
representative Jakob of ik home alone in
the room
representative Bert he's also not here
okay and one more time is representative
Judy around he's not present missed the
call from him could someone on staff
give him a call maybe he's having
trouble getting access Brad could you
give him a call
let's pause just a moment let's till we
hear representative goli here and my
wife may be in a row at home
okay so we're waiting on Judy to wrap it
up yes and Brad's calling him right now
okay so we're in momentary recess Pam
can I start this now and we can have him
do the roll call in the middle or do we
have to wait he can when he enters he
can announce his presence and where he
is that's that's fine just like any any
other meeting you might attend a little
late all right okay I know some people
who have things to do and others have
had a busy morning already and I'm
probably looking get some fresh air and
enjoy this weather
so we'll start opening up the executive
session House bill 1692 and I will move
amendment 2 0 2 0 1 2 4 6 H and a second
by representative Schmitt I see
what was that number please choices 1 2
yes 2 0 2 0 1 2 4 6 H 6 1 2 4 6 ok so I
got 3 but 6 is the number ok I think
there was a previous amendment that was
1 2 4 3 this is a new amendment correct
and this is similar to the amendment we
had in the work session the only change
that was made in this amendment versus
the amendment we discussed in the work
session was the effective date taking
effect July 1st 2021
knowing that listening to Health and
Human Services that they would be able
to roll it over into that next budget
and unsure about whether or not it would
be feasible to do this year with what's
going on and I will recognize represents
MIT if he wants to speak to a second
well that the change is incidental but
important and so the the underlying
amendment which we've already discussed
quite thoroughly is you know a move as
step forward in my opinion we need to
get this done it's clear that HHS wants
this the the practitioners want it and
it's in the best interest of the people
of New Hampshire in my opinion
discussion on the amendment there was a
Pimentel I see you in a city I see you
well it's not actually about the
amendment it's about the whole bill but
I can wait okay any further discussion
on the amendment seeing none the clerk
call the roll
representing Cooley I'm sorry to
interrupt but it looks like new duties
is on the line
Oh is he an attendee or season
yeah but nd yes not nd okay we move him
up that's as good as we're able to do
but you he'll be able to speak and hear
everything that's happening have you
renamed your saying Jeff oh there we go
welcome represent thank you thank you
David and I will now ask the clerk to
call the roll
our amendment 1 2 4 6 H of passing from
the amendment representative show it I'm
sorry
representative show it ah hello
representative sure it's I'm muting
herself it is tricky there unfortunately
yeah I vote YES on the amendment
representative Joo Dee yes buddy I'm in
mint representative Schmidt Schmidt
votes YES on the amendment
representative Schultz yes
representative footnote yes
representative
yes okay represent Desert Inn yes
representative fellows yes
representative box yes representative
Grodin yes
representative merchant yes on the
amendment representative Pimentel
I'm sorry representative Pimentel are
you there yep
the answer is yo okay representing
McGuire yes on the amendment purposes
the clerk votes yes representative
Bowden yes on the amendment
representative proof representative
proof yes yes on the amendment
represented Penta City yes on the same
representative PS Pearson is not here
but represented Pearson representative
Jakub of it
yes in them and Representatives Bert not
at present we have representative goalie
yes
looks like 1918 zero vote of 18 to 0 the
motion on the amendment the amendment is
adopted
representative fellows do you have a
motion yes I'd like to move on to pass
on HP's 1692 with amendment 2021 2 4 6 H
representative Fellowes moves ought to
pass with amendment on House bill 1692
seconded by representative Schmidt and
would you like to speak to your motion
represent fellows yes thank you
um this bill will allow wild mushrooms
to be sold legally in New Hampshire so
that creates a new source of business
revenue somebody will be able to sell
mushrooms to restaurants and to grocery
stores in a farmer's markets to be able
to have a license to do this will
require taking a course and passing a
test so that the mushrooms that are sold
will be safe for the public and we heard
from Health and Human Services that they
were supportive
this bill into that with the amendment
giving them some extra time they could
implement this licensing and sort the
costs within their existing budget
represents MIT would you like to speak
to you a second here muted one second
presentative now you can speak Thank You
representative fellows has already
touched on all the important points but
I'd like to just emphasize the safety
aspect mushrooms are a wonderful thing
unless they're not so to speak because
there are poisonous and unhealthy wild
mushrooms out there which should not be
you know mixed into the restaurants fair
bill affair or anywhere else for that
matter because they can lead to gastric
distress and even death so this is an
important step in terms of allowing our
existing industry in this field to to
begin to work under safe conditions and
into the benefit of our public both in
terms of enjoying something that is
helpful and tasty and safe if the if
this amended bill goes forward further
discussion represent bulletins Thank You
mr. chairman
I'm going to vote in opposition to this
bill for a number of reasons firstly as
Representative McGuire pointed out the
bill exceeds the requirements that the
federal Food and Drug Administration is
set forth well that's my first position
of opposition secondly I think the
penalties for violating the statute
should the bill become law are excessive
at $1,000 per incident but most
importantly I think as someone else
pointed out previously this is a really
a solution and searchable problem
exciting the National Institutes of
Health National Library
of Medicine bill study in 2018 and to
put it in a nutshell
there's no there's seventy four hundred
and twenty eight cases of mushroom
poisoning a year eighty-three percent
over 83% of those poisoning cases cause
no or only minor high boils down to
about thirty nine exposures a year that
caused major harm in only two point nine
deaths per year from ingesting mushrooms
most of which were unintentional ingest
patients by elderly so this is an
unnecessary law so I'll be enough thank
you presenter McGuire has her hand up
represent quiet yes thank you I'm also
going to be voting against this it's as
represent bowed and said it's
unnecessary
I've bought wild mushrooms at farmers
markets in the past and the most common
and most and tastiest wild mushrooms
that you can get around here are really
hard to to miss to misidentify yes there
are poisonous ones but they don't look
like the tasty ones and it doesn't take
a lot of training to find them out what
this does is not make it it makes it it
doesn't make it legal to pick and sell
mushrooms it makes illegal to do so
without a license and I find that
excessive and heavy-handed and I also
believe that we're letting the federal
government by it's excessive regulations
cause us to add more to our already
heavy burden of regulations and so we're
making the problem worse by passing this
bill and I'm definitely going to be
voting against it thank you
Thank You mr. chairman I just got an
email from somebody who was it
and and I didn't read this because they
just got it so individual wants to know
if the landowners Commission is still in
the bill and if the Mike Road all just
is off that was the questions that they
asked and I didn't know that because I
came right there and didn't have time to
look it up yes to answer the part about
the landowners I would I would assume
that they're still in support of this I
forgot to mention it but the bill
contains a provision that somebody
cannot harvest mushrooms on somebody
else's land without their permission so
they're still in favor of that and I
have a follow up mr. chairman represent
fantasy is is that a commission or is it
just landowners Association the way that
was asked to me was there's a landowners
Commission that sits on this the that
provision was added by the environment
and Agriculture Committee and it had the
support of the timber owners association
and the Society for the Protection of
New Hampshire forests and I think some
other organizations supported it also
have another follow up then
No so does that mean that they are they
the landowners Commission is a part of
this bill there is a there is a
landowners Commission that's associated
with this particular bill or they just
agree with it I don't a legislative
Commission is that what you're referring
to that's what I took it as I don't know
I didn't I don't know what that is I've
never heard of that maybe that maybe
they just didn't know what it was they
just wanted to make sure that the
landowners come
is still there I know the landowners and
the timber owners associations were
testified in support of that one
amendment that was one of the biggest
issues that that committee dealt with it
the agriculture the environment
agriculture committee okay thank you
Schmidt that on the issue the
representative Bowden raised with regard
to the fine is it $1000 per instance or
is it up to $1,000 per instance the bill
states up to okay in other words it
could be $50 or $100 and not $1,000
correct which is I understand if I
understand English
I believe that pretty much boilerplate
in a lot of the statues we have the up
to leaving it up to the rules in the
Department just wanted to make sure
we're merging Thank You mr. chair
- mr. Hanna City representative
Tennessee's comment about the landowner
goat I think on page 2 line 17 number 9
speaks - it's not so much the
Association but they cannot go on to the
land without the permission of the
landowner thank you representing yes
thank you mr. chair I as somebody who
come from an island like I know the
world mushroom is poisonous I would like
to know if there is a special way
they're going to prepare that to remove
the part of it who who has the the
poisonous which wish has the poisonous
represents ellos representative duty the
mushrooms that are in the United State
there are hundreds of different
varieties of mushrooms and some of them
are perfectly safe
and a very few of them are perfectly
safe and tastes good and those world
will be the ones that the people will be
selling and they have to take a course
to make sure that they can identify the
few mushrooms that are on the permitted
list and so that's how we'll keep people
safe okay Thank You representative fun
yes I'm supporting this bill initially I
didn't think I would because I was
considering it unnecessary regulation
but I am supporting it because the what
I understand now is it's more enabling
legislation than it is regulating and
that we have an issue with a number of
the health inspector code enforcement
type people disallowing restaurants from
using ingredients that are not on and
approved list someplace and I know we
ran into that in Rochester with another
with another product and I think that
this falls into the same category that
technically right now they're not
allowed to be using these mushrooms
because there's no there's no avenue to
allow it and I think that this
legislation opens that up and and and
creates an Avenue so that we can use the
wild mushrooms that are harvested so I
will support it represent Phillips yes
I'm just as a follow-up to that I was on
the mushroom Commission and one of the
stories that we heard from Colleen Smith
at the HHS Department of Food Services
is that when their inspectors go to
restaurants if they find that there are
wild mushrooms they're in the kit
they tell the restaurant that they have
to throw them away because the federal
guidelines say that they cannot sell
wild mushrooms and let they have been
approved by a regulating authority so a
regulating authority can be the state in
other states it might be at the county
level I think there's some confusion
because in the commission's report this
citation that's in there is not the one
that actually matches what I would I
just said it was somewhere else in the
in the federal regulations mr. chairman
just so you're aware representative
Turner is in the attendees and he has
his hand up he was the prime sponsor of
the bill I don't know if you want to
recognize him during the executive
session they're not but that's just you
know okay I'm gonna take questions from
the committee first and then we'll go
and see from there represent of shooing
we're working on mute in addition okay
thank you I'm learning I just wanted to
point out that the bill does require
that if you are enabled by this bill to
pick wild mushrooms you have to label
them as to the source which if there is
a problem when a restaurant or say a
farmers market sells them this will make
it more easily traceable how to go back
to the source thank you any other
comments or questions from the committee
representing our
all right
you should be able to talk about
represented I am mooted now okay thank
you thank you very thought to answer the
earlier question the landowners are not
part of the bill there's not any kind of
a commission or anything it's just
precisely what representative fellows
said they testified in favor of the bill
and actually credit goes to
representative fellows for getting that
amendment in they got the support of the
landowners I mean the timber owners and
then amp sure society frigate
preservation of Horace likewise there is
no mycologist who is on any commission
what the reason that got in there is
when it initially was the responsibility
of da MF they thought he needed a my
question to be Minister the that really
necessary since mycologists have helped
develop already the list and the program
they might want to consult with a
mycologist but they're not part of the
bill whatsoever so the person who was
saying that really wasn't familiar with
the bill at all I think all the other
questions have been pretty well answered
again an issue that when inspections are
made any food being used in a restaurant
or sold in a grocery store has to be
properly sourced and it's simply that if
there is not an approval of the mushroom
then it is not properly sourced and as
portunity fellow said it would have
carted and kanai's so that's what it
amounts to thank you thank you for the
discussion represent Pina City have we
have we ever asked the question what the
revenue amount would be through on this
how much money would restaurants make on
on wild mushrooms or what's the what's
the revenue represented fellows I can
tell you that and you may remember this
from last year from 2019 when we had the
bill to create the Commission to study
licensing mushrooms harvesters that we
heard from one person who told us that
he made 40
thousand dollars in one year selling
mushrooms to rest
I would think primarily to restaurants
so that was probably a good year
mushrooms are very finicky you can have
great years and then you can have
droughts essentially so there's a lot of
variability but there are some kinds of
wild mushrooms that cost 35 50 $60 a
pound retail so there there could be a
significant amount of money for some
people I don't think too many people are
going to get into this market but it's
not insignificant ya know
the other thing that strikes me about
this bill so if you're in the market to
harvest these things they're you
harvesting just from New Hampshire is
this a harvest from anywhere in the
country represent Phillips so this would
be the license that you need to harvest
mushrooms that are on the ground in New
Hampshire and to to sell and you could
sell them in New Hampshire or you could
sell them somewhere else if the other
state if the other state has a law that
allows that see I'd I'd might not have
been listening to this and it might have
been said already but does New Hampshire
have mushrooms that people want I mean
definitely ok I think we heard from a
number of folks who are currently
harvesting and we also heard from folks
from the restaurant industry that we're
fully behind this because it was
something they were looking for right ok
just refresh my memory thank you
any other comments questions before we
go forward and we want to welcome
represent a Pierson and you could just
state where you're at and if there's
anyone with you for the roll call
I am in a Manchester building right now
and there is currently nobody in the
office with me okay and represent of
Judy could you do the same I don't think
we got you to do that when you came I am
alone in my office
thank you we represented merchants Thank
You mr. chair a question to maybe two
reps and a fellow's in regards to the
licensure if somebody is picking up
mushrooms from another state and they
want to sell them in the state of New
Hampshire will they be required to have
a state license from New Hampshire well
New Hampshire recognize that little
places tell you that definitively I have
a guess but I could do that then we get
Colleen Smith to answer that question
Colleen Smith is here representative
canook has his hand up and Colleen has
her hand up now so would you like
recognize Colin Smith okay that's that
question
Colleen you should be able to talk there
you go I see her
yeah okay he's muted right there she is
I'm sorry I allowed her to talk for she
I am I
hopefully yeah you can hear me now I
again from at the record my name is
Colleen Smith I'm the administrator of
the food protection section within the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services so with regard to the
previous question if a harvester
wild mushrooms in another state they
would need to be approved to do so by
that state's regulatory authority in
order to be as recognized as an approved
source for sale in a New Hampshire food
establishment thank you represent
McGuire all right Thank You mr. chair I
was just going to say that as I read the
bill it says first of all that we will
respect other states licenses for
Pickers but it also seems to me that if
someone were to have the permission of
the landowner they could easily pick in
Maine say and and then sell them in New
Hampshire if they were licensed in New
Hampshire I mean they need the
permission of the landowner but that
doesn't say that the pick you need to
pick them only in the answer any other
comments or questions from the committee
thank you I think that pointer
represented McGuire has just raised is
one that that actually adds to the
significance of the regulatory scheme
that we are creating here and that is
that if you have somebody who was a
trained harvester slash picker of
mushrooms and they are in another state
and then and they know what they're
looking for
they know what's good they know what's
bad if they are harvesting mushrooms and
they are a person of training and
expertise then this is an asset to a
restaurants menu to have something which
is delicious and nutritious so I think
that that is not an impediment to our
going forward any other question
represents an attack hi I think I think
much has been said I think I would um I
would vote for this bill except for the
fact that during the work session I
raised I noticed what I could consider
technical difficulties and if
presentative McGuire is correct that
this goes beyond federal requirements I
that seems to me and to be an overreach
I don't know that but at this point I
don't have the desire especially to
introduce an amendment that probably
wouldn't go anywhere anyway so I I see
that we're being more or less compelled
we are being compelled by the federal
government whether I like that or not
some material we have to do it but I
would like to see a clean I'd like to
see these issues resolved I'm not going
to be the one to suggest it to or to did
to do it the hour is late let's vote
thank you thank you yeah took me a
minute to get my cursor on a mute I just
wanted to point out that part of the
labeling part in the bill states that
you have to put the county where the
mushrooms were harvested so that would
again source whether it was in New
Hampshire or in some other state
obviously that County name would not
likely jive with any of ours thank you
and representative connor briefly and
then
if there's no other questions oh just
wanted to note that the question of
purchasing from auto stayed on page 2 of
the bill lines the first where it's a
sale of mushrooms and that's what points
out that it has to be in accordance with
the subdivision unless purchased from an
out-of-state source approved by that
source or country of origin so in other
words if you have a main Harvester who
is approved by a program there ain't no
Hampshire Restaurant can purchase from
them so that's so that allows the fact
that other states may do it it's a it's
an element of reciprocity thank you
thank you any other comments or
questions
now all right being none I will just
state again I think we had numerous
folks testify from both restaurant
industry as well as looking for this
this is part of the National Food Code
that was adopted by Health and Human
Services and it is language there that
requires this to be done if you're going
to sell and dispense of wild mushrooms
so I'm going to support this and if
there's no further discussion the motion
of ought to pass with amendment made by
represented fellow second if I
represented Schmitt and the clerk can
call the roll
representative show it on the bill of
them with amendments
yes I vote yes yes
representative Schmidt mid-40s
representative Schultz yes
representative Fontenot
I see a thumbs up he's not unmuted okay
yeah represent if I know you said yes
representation and yes representative
fellows yes
representative Fox yes
represent do I hear representative Fox
yes okay
Thank You representative crota yes
represented merchants yes
representative Tim Intel representative
Inman tell yes I hear represent Maguire
now clerk foots no representative Boden
no representative Pro yes
representative Penta City yes
representative Pearson the
representative Pearson yes
representative Jakob ovitch no
representative bird is not attending and
the chair there votes yes okay for mmm
15 for 15 Emma Craddock mushrooms to for
Republican mushrooms 15 to 4 with a vote
of 15 to 4 the most not to pass as
amendment is adopted and I want to thank
everyone for participating today and
looking forward to seeing everyone on
June 11th get out and enjoy some of the
weather now where you take care and
can't wait to see you in the zoot suit
again
okay